hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
this video is gonna be a little bit
different I wanted to switch it up for
today for the hero concept series that
we've been doing I was browsing reddit
as one does and I came across an entire
slideshow of factions and heroes very
similar to the one from last video but
not just one hero but multiple heroes
and factions together it's like 60
slides along it has new ideas for the
Knights the Vikings the samurai the
wolven and an even new faction that this
person created which is the Moors
faction I'll leave a link to it if you
want to see it for yourself I highly
recommend looking at the samurai and the
Viking factions because those are easily
one of my favorite ones that they've
added but this morris faction has like
eight characters so I'm gonna be
splitting this up into two parts first
we're gonna be looking at the first half
of the heroes which is kind of like the
intro or these starting characters like
how the Wulin had four at one time and
then the last four will be in a separate
video cuz if I added all those together
this would be like twenty to thirty
minutes long and that's gonna be like
the future DLC characters added
throughout the seasons of the game
because there's a lot of backstory for
all these characters and I think leaving
these separate it would be a really good
idea but yeah as always like to be if
you do enjoy subscribe if you're new I
cover the informational site a foreigner
that being the balance changes the here
updates the patch notes and the leaks
gonna be kept of today with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
and never miss out on an update that
fuiste subscribe the channel and with
that let's get started with today's
video so quickly before we get started
we have to talk about the lore of this
specific faction and where they reside
their upbringing so to speak and it says
here the moors are warriors who came
from hot climates of the south the
Knights and their empires threatened to
Moorish lands long ago and now they've
returned for vengeance the Moors have
recruited many other southern warriors
to their cause and are now unified and
ready to join this multi-sided war used
two deserts in savannas the fertile and
more comfortable lands in the north
seemed ripe for the tanking even after
the Cataclysm to add a little bit more
to this they are mostly made of Muslim
warriors that inhabited the Arabian
desert so a lot of these characters
you'll be seeing will be shown around
those areas of the world and I'm
picturing their lands to be like the
marching fire intro where there's just
desert everywhere and it's hot as [ __ ]
so first up is the vanguard of the
faction mom Luke he's considered a
medium difficulty with a straightforward
move set that is heavily reliant on
bombo's mom Luke will be living a
scimitar by the looks of the image it
seems to be a two-handed variant of the
weapon the fighting style is based
around combos with different properties
like unblockable Zhan da gerbils etc and
the character is heavily based on these
Saracen warriors for the mom Luke's
specific lore on their reasoning for
being here it says mom Luke's are among
the most experienced moorish warriors
slavery forced them into a life of
warfare but battle after battle felling
foes with their scimitars they have now
been masters in their own way so these
guys were pretty much essentially slaves
at one point then turned their life
around and became hardened warriors and
our masters at doing so another quote
that he added states that war forces
many hands too cruel action enslavement
was not becoming of our people until war
made it necessary and as it so happens
out of necessity comes perfection mom
Luke's have been honed to a fine edge by
their troubled upbringing once forced
into battle they now charge into it
willingly scimitars flashing fearlessly
as they march on to the next victory
moving on to the faction we have some of
these images that I'm showing on screen
I think the original one that I showed
in the beginning would be more of that
end game legendary rep 7 and above type
gear and I would say the two middle and
this image in terms of armor could
definitely be like the intro rep 1 rep 0
type gear with the 2 on the sides maybe
being middle like purple or gold like
rep 3 rep 5 I think that'd be a nice
growth point to where the armor could go
a lot of the weapons seem to be changing
depending on how many curves there is or
curves in different directions which I
really do personally enjoy overall if I
had to pick this character straight up I
think I definitely be using the mom Luke
as much as possible very cool looking
character definitely has some potential
for some really good looking armor and
I've always been a big fan of the
scimitars and Skyrim so that's
definitely gonna be a good weapon of
choice for the character next up is the
heavy of the faction called the
immortals and we've covered them a bit
in a past video which you can see in the
top right but this guy goes a lot more
in-depth with his kind of variation and
twist on it like I said these are the
heavies of the faction with a medium
difficulty they're more about disabling
the opponent and using defensive stances
the weapon of choice is the spear and
large shield
so it seems to be a mix of Valkyrie and
warlord in terms of the weaponry they're
also inspired by the Persian immortals
which like I mentioned before we've
discussed already in a past video the
Syrian warriors and the bronze age
warriors as well their traditional
frontline soldiers with their fighting
style being heavily on defensive stances
with blocks in two directions at one
time and opposite of where the attack is
and having a knockdown shield charge so
out the gate I like the original idea
for the stance so if the a person's
guard is on the top that means the
stance will be blocking both sides or if
the guard is on the right that means the
stance is gonna be blocking left and top
I'm not really sure how this is going to
work as that attack direction he
mentioned is where the person blocks
just like any other character so maybe
it's this weird hybrid of reflex and
normal guard where the indicator is the
attack so usually when you fight
characters on a one-on-one you don't
want to attack where they're guarding as
it's going to be automatically blocked
but maybe in this instance that's where
you want to attack as that he doesn't
really have a defensive indicator and
where he is going is where he attacks
from and the defensive stance is his
block indication maybe that's how this
plays out I think that's gonna be really
cool if that actually is a thing but at
least that's my interpretation of it it
seems maybe like a different variation a
full block though so maybe my idea isn't
too correct but it's just something to
think about the quotes both say the
immortals have been on the frontline
soldiers from for the Moors as long as I
can remember
they've taken inspiration from many
cultures they've fought against but
still rely on the heavy tradition of the
spear and shield since man could first
forged metal since armies first came
together the tradition of the Immortals
has stood strong defenders of ancient
empires the rank have been on the front
line of every war for the people they
fought for they've had their fair share
of losses but not enough to end them for
good a single immortal may die but their
legend gives them their namesake a spear
and shield may be a simple configuration
but there are reasons they're still used
to this day
well not better than the mom Luke to me
personally I think this faction is
showing good signs so far just of these
two characters of having fantastic
fashion and that it's obviously more
important than fighting skill can't
fight good if you don't look good is
what I always say I notice characters
like hito Keary and warlord have really
nice weapon customizations all the time
since there's a lot more room to make
stuff with as opposed to a character
like a roachie who doesn't really have
much room to make different designs with
so I think the shield is gonna be the
same way in terms of the high tier armor
the assassin and the third character of
the group is called the Hisashi n-- they
are medium difficulty as well and the
of the group with the character being
more of a short-range melee specialists
their weapon of choice is the Jambi a
dagger they were more inspired by the
Arabian Warriors and they use a fighting
style of grapple centric knife fighting
pinning attacks and bleed deflects
honestly I would pay more money that I
would like to disclose in this video so
I could play this character the armour
and the weapon is already top tier and
it's only the first image we've seen of
this character at the moment bleed d
flecks are a nice touch as that weapon
will surely make somebody bleed and the
idea of being extremely up close to the
opponent and pinning them with moves
like shamans bite for an example is
really interesting as for the quotes the
first assassins to ever walk the earth
the [ __ ] Sheen's are the Masters of
secrets and the art of death they only
need one single dagger the Jambi ax to
take into battle their skills do the
rest
assassins exist the world over but who
do you think was the first who gave them
their name the ash machines have been in
the shadows since before we knew they
existed and even now that we do we still
know so little
stealthy quick in the most skilled my
fighters to ever live there can be no
doubt why so many follow in their silent
footsteps for customization we are
already three four three young
good-looking characters so far the
middle for sure is endgame gear
obviously the crossbow is it going to be
part of the character although that
could be used as a third feet it won't
come with the actual weapon of the
character but others could really go
anywhere but as for the other armors
those could go pretty much anywhere in
the categories of low rep gear middle
rep or high rep gear I like the idea of
the knife getting more royalty looking
as we go along although if I'm being
honest I feel like those assassins
wouldn't really like that kind of thing
they want to stick to the shadows and
have the darkest and more plain looking
gear that they would so desire but
honestly this is a fantastic weapon
regardless and the character has a ton
of potential for the armor as there's so
many different variations some would
choose somewhat not some with more
clothing some less clothing a whole lot
of options for some customization going
on here and the last character of this
group is the hybrid and then that is the
Sultan the Sultan is hard difficulty the
only hard difficulty so far for this
faction and is a hybrid with
hard-hitting attacks and some ranged
attacks as well the weapon of choice is
a combo of the mace and with
probably one in each hand like many of
the two weapon characters we have within
the game the inspiration was obviously
other Sultan's and slave Lords as well
the Sultan for the story would be a
cruel slave master that uses the
long-range whip attacks and grapples
then gets within with those hard-hitting
close-up attacks using the mace so some
nice combo dynamics going on already for
the character the slave Lord Sultan's
have entered into the battlefield poised
to punish the undisciplined and enslave
those who submit their whips were once
tool is used to inflict pain only but
when paired with the bone-crushing mace
a sultan becomes a deadly warrior
discipline cannot exist without
punishments and empires cannot exist
without labor Sultan's make sure these
things exist in multitudes while their
wrathful nature and occupation do not
sit well with many one would always
prefer a sultan on their side a whip
alone is fearful to unarmed and distant
foes but their mace crushes their armor
sending the undisciplined to their doom
the armor customization is nice for this
character as it looks pretty close to
Hal Sultan's look like and lots of
cloths with them gems and armor to show
the wealth they have procured through
their slave trade I'm an extremely huge
fan of the all-white version on the
right the weapons shown on the bottom
could have it the normal multi tailed
whip with the high-end weapons having
one chain but being spiked or serrated
on it which is cool the mace doesn't
seem to be flashy with many versions
shown in the picture but not everything
needs to be flashy I think for
customization dynamic as there's two
weapons it would probably be the staff
in the head for the mace and then the
whip altogether would change as we need
three spots for customizing the weapons
and that pretty much settles it with
this faction and this may be a hot take
but if this faction existed within for
honor they might be the most fashionable
faction in the game even rivaling the
Knights they are currently now four for
four if I had to give it an order I
would say the assassin is definitely my
most favorite followed by the Sultan and
the mom Luke and then the immortal being
the worst even though the immortal
really isn't even that bad he's still
very fashionable someone needed to be
ranked last on that list yeah that's
gonna be the end of the bay today guys
hope you guys did enjoy like the V if
you do let me know in the comments down
below what your favorite hero is in this
made-up faction in the comments down
below and if you do enjoy be sure to
look out for part two as that will be
coming up eventually and we'll be
covering some of the court unquote DLC
characters for this
faction is like called them to now go to
the closer I'd like to be for doing joy
subscribe for new I cover the
information on the side of foreigner
that being the balance changes the hero
updates the Patchett's in the leaks if
your undercuts us today with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
and never miss out or not they
definitely say subscribe the channel
that take care guys hope you girls today
peace out
[Music]
you